Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen thomas.
Guten morgen themen.
Könnt ihr mich jetzt hören.
Hört ihr mich jetzt oder.
Hallo tim du ruckelst ein bisschen warte mal also video funktioniert.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer zweihundertfünfunddreißig direkt live aus der quarantäne,
podcast wesens und ihr merkt schon.
Die dinge sind anders.
Exakt eine stunde gebraucht.
Nur um dieses set-up hinzubekommen und es ist ein kleines drama aber das ist noch das geringste drama durch das wenn du gerade alle durch müssen und ich glaube das braucht auch noch eine weile bis ich das ein ruckelt.
Hallo.
Schön gesagt.
Wir begrüßen thomas hallo.
Hallo.
Live zugeschaltet aus österreich aus wien und linus ist natürlich auch zugeschaltet denn auch die metaebene muss jetzt distanz waren.
Natürlich keine soziale distanz.
Physische distanz.
Genau weil das ist irgendwie das unwort der woche habe ich so ein bisschen den eindruck ne diese social distanz ist ja.
Eigentlich der falsche begriff weil es geht ja nicht darum soziale distanz zu halten sondern es geht ja eher darum.
Physischen abstand zu halten und das ist eigentlich alles was erforderlich ist muss ich ja nicht gleich sozial distanzieren.
Ja sowieso erstaunlich wie viel die leute irgendwie um,
also ich habe ernsthaft in einer leute relativ wenig verstehen worum es genau geht nämlich einfach wirklich darum dass es halt so wenig menschen wie möglich.
Nah kommt das auch eigentlich alles also ist ja der der der einzige faktor der wirklich eine rolle spielt auch wenn du also naja aber
wenn ich hier in berlin jetzt so mir das wochenende anschaue haben den teil die leute nicht so ganz verstanden scheint mir.
Ja ich meine das sieht man auch mal wieder wie unterschiedlich die die informationslage ist oder wie unterschiedlich auch vielleicht in unterschiedlichen bevölkerungs.
Informationsverarbeitung kapazität würde ich eher.
Ja sagen wir mal wie guck mal wir sind ja so informationsapp hin.
Wir mögen es informationen heranzuziehen möglichst viele davon zu haben zu sortieren und ein bild zu machen das ist so unser sport das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt bei allen leuten so.
Also nicht informationsapp ist auf jeden fall mein lieblingsort vermiss muss für vollidioten.
Nicht informationsapp hin.
Man muss ja auch freundlich sein.
Wer überleben will muss freundlich sein.
Informationsabend.
Aber top.
Information oder sowas.
Ja ja.
Matthias.
Thomas gib uns doch mal kurz den eindruck weil in österreich sind die dinge ja etwas dramatischer noch erstmal seid ihr ja wieder schuld ne.
Und außerdem seid ihr natürlich auch an dem an dem drama zentrum italien noch sehr viel näher dran.
Abgesehen davon dass natürlich die ganzen skigebiete in der schweiz österreich italien alle so ihren teil dazu beigetragen haben weil er einfach eben in diesen zeiten sehr viele touristen sind für kurze zeit sich dort eng mit allen leuten rumgekuschelt haben und dann schwups,
im easyjet wieder nach hause geflogen sind und das schön über europa verteilt haben.
Da kann man natürlich dem land jetzt keinen vorwurf machen bevor das jetzt hier gleich wieder falsch verstanden wird aber das ist halt passiert so ne und dementsprechend sind ja die maßnahmen bei euch jetzt auch schon etwas krasser als zum beispiel jetzt bei uns im norden.
Also dem dem muss man leider zustimmen also da gibt es inzwischen auch einige gute.
Die wir verlinken werden österreich ist leider der hotspot,
aus dem viele andere ansteckungen in europa passiert sind und du hast es schon gesagt er war vor allem der wintersport dafür verantwortlich da gab es im einen gewissen,
barkeeper der in italien war sich dort angesteckt hat und dann eben in in tirol im wintersportgebiete noch gearbeitet hat auf engem raum so abriss skihütten und dort
eine unmenge an menschen angesteckt hat
du hast schon recht mund auf dem land keine schuld geben aber den behörden muss man an dieser stelle klar schuld geben weil es war so dass in anderen
eu-ländern island zum beispiel und norwegen auch diese spezifischen winter tourismus orte in österreich schon als hochrisiko.
Jeder der von dort zurückkam wurde sofort in quarantäne gestellt und in österreich ist immer noch tagelang nichts passiert
auch das eis was passiert ist und dieses wintersportgebiete geschlossen hat gut
sind die leute halt irgendwie noch nach innsbruck gefahren in den nächst größere stadt und haben nochmal einen tag dort verbracht bis ihr flieger geht was nochmal mehr leute angesteckt hat,
ein jetzt ist irgendwie das ganze bundesland tirol unter quarantäne und die aufarbeitung ist erst ganz am anfang aber schaut so aus dass die wirtschaftlichen interessen
der wintersportregion dir sehr mächtig in österreich sind da dazu geführt haben dass man sich gedacht hat na komm aber ein paar tage können wir das noch irgendwie laufen lassen und dadurch das problem und den ernst der lage nicht erkannt hat.
Die jetzige situation in österreich ist wahrscheinlich ein paar.
Tage oder wochen vor dem was in deutschland vielleicht kommen wird also wir haben ausgangs beschränkungen.
Wir kommen nachher noch zu den gesetzen die in österreich,
beschlossen worden die haben wir uns natürlich genau angeschaut aber an sich es ist eine situation wo das land wirklich also es wird ganz klar in österreich diese situation verglichen mit dem zweiten weltkrieg wir hatten so eine krise seit dem zweiten weltkrieg,
und die bundesregierung macht aber einen außerordentlich guten,
von dem wie sie das ganze handelt natürlich passieren denn auch fehler aber zumindest wird es nicht ignoriert wie in anderen ländern.
Das gesundheitssystem ist noch.
Unter seiner belastungsgrenze also da ist noch luft und ich habe selbst familie die in dem bereich arbeitet
an der vordersten front insofern schaue ich mir das sehr genau an an so ist das soziale leben ist,
allergrößten teil zum erliegen gekommen ein sich in bei dem guten wetter sind leider halt immer noch in parks aber es wird auch großteils abstand gehalten so weit ich das
natürlich ganz objektiv irgendwie beobachtet habe wenn ich alleine draußen war einfach weil man kann auch nicht nur drinnen sein aber physischen abstand halten,
das das tun die leute auch man sieht so richtig dass sie die straßenseite wechseln also individuelles verhalten hat sich schon angepasst dass das ist bei vielen menschen inzwischen angekommen glaube ich.
Ja gut zu hören ich bin mir da für berlin noch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher man nimmt's natürlich dann auch nicht mehr so ganz wahr wenn man selbst sich dran hält aber
die feierwütige zeit war in berlin dann doch schwer in griff zu kriegen,
ich hoffe dass ich das mittlerweile gebessert hat weil sonst wird's halt ja auch sehr schnell sehr ungemütlich denke ich.
Also ich habe auch nicht unbedingt den eindruck dass hier.
In meinem umfeld in berlin wo ich wohne und mir draußen in die situation anschaue allen irgendwie,
alle so die informationen affinen
scheint dann doch weniger zu sein also ich habe bin ich ganz ehrlich mir auch als dann angela merkel eine ansprache als kanzlerin ankündigte gesagt okay,
aber das ist ja dann leider auch nur bei freundlichen worten geblieben.
Wir schaffen das.
Hat sie ja schon schon mal gesagt ohne dann irgendwie maßnahmen die notwendigen maßnahmen zu ergreifen und ich werde jetzt schon an dem punkt gewesen mir das eigentlich zu wünschen dass.
Das hier mal klarer,
durchgegriffen wird weil ja wie du schon sagtest die feier wut in berlin ist ungebrochen wenn man abends sein,
alleine seinen kleinen spaziergang macht dann sieht man immer noch irgendwelche horden von jugendlichen,
die irgendwie weißt du joints und gemischte getränke teilen am spielplatz rumhängen und du denkst dir wirklich ob die.
Ob die schlechten strauchen oder so.
Das ist eine super schwierige situation aber gleichzeitig man merkt jetzt auch so wenn man sich die reaktionen der verschiedenen
länder anschaut alleine an den ansprachen die regierungschefs was ist neben allen maßnahmen von ausgangs- beschränkung geschäft schließungen grenzen zu machen das ist noch eine andere funktion gibt
wenn wenn politik in dieser situation wirklich sagen kann leute ist es ernst bitte tut jetzt das und diese regierung hat legitimation
in der bevölkerung ist das wahrscheinlich einer der sinnvollsten maßnahmen die man setzen kann weil am ende geht es um unser individuelles verhalten um das risiko zu minimieren und das
hat zum beispiel in spanien extrem schlecht funktioniert weil die regierung dort irgendwie mehr zigmal gewählt und da fehlt diese legitimation und dadurch werden diese diese aufrufe auch nicht ernst genommen und
in wirklichkeit bei all diesen maßnahmen ist viele sowieso die polizei das landesweit zu entschlossen es braucht am ende die kooperation damit wir da,
möglichst gut durchkommen ich habe diese rede von merkel nicht gehört ich habe aber viel gutes darüber vernommen und.
Sebastian kurz hat muss man auch sagen also der kids kanzler ist erwachsen geworden also alleine vom vom.
Wie er irgendwie auch diese ansprache manager macht er das verdammt gut und ich bin ich bin gerade sehr zufrieden dass wir die aktuelle regierung in österreich haben und nicht mehr die vorherige mit fpö.
Okay thomas hat fieber tim da müssen wir jetzt auch.
Aber ich meine das ist natürlich man muss ja auch man muss ja auch mal die chancen sehen so und ob das alles so kommen wird weiß ich nicht aber erstmal was ich was ich wahrnehme ist.
Viele leute begreifen dass es jetzt.
Ernst ist und man kann jetzt nicht irgendwie sich weiter durch eiern das wird mittelfristig sogar bei trump ankommen.
Wenn er das so durch seine seine sein besteck ist für dieses mal nicht geeignet daran dabei ist er sich wirklich die zähne aus an diesem problem das wird ihnen,
sozusagen sofort in den in den abgrund mitreißen die sind gezwungen,
sich dieser realität zu stellen wer das nicht tut wird sehr schnell rausgekegelt werden allein schon weil man sich selber dann mit seinem verhalten virus einfängt und dann einfach verstirbt,
und alle kommen auf einen zu und es ist auch sozusagen.
In gewisser hinsicht absurd ja dass dass dass wir in einer aus einer zeit gerade herauskommen die so von so rassismus vorbehalten und so weiter so so enorm geprägt war die ganze politische kultur der letzten zwei drei jahre
irgendwie nicht nicht dran vorbei kam aber wir uns jetzt sozusagen ein feind gegenüber sehen wo jedem klar wird
da kann man jetzt mit schuldzuweisungen nicht mehr viel erreichen ist halt ein fucking virus betrifft halt irgendwie alle ist an sich auch eine schöne botschaft was man so sehen will so na also
egal was die hautfarbe ist egal wie deine physiologie geneigt ist völlig egal ja,
wir sind dann doch offensichtlich alle eine spezies und eben auf die selbe art und weise bedroht und wer halt in in dieser stelle nicht in der lage ist
auch sich entsprechend zu verhalten und aufzustellen insbesondere bei den.
Staatslenker drinnen und lenker so wird einfach sehr schnell im offline.
Das halte ich aber für eine katastrophale fehleinschätzung tim die beiden dinge haben ja nichts miteinander zu tun,
also du kannst einerseits klar als führerin eines staates jetzt nicht ausreichende maßnahmen ergreifen oder ausreichende aber das ist,
grundsätzlich eine ganz andere frage wen wir für verantwortlich machst ja und
trump der das corona virus ja jetzt schon einfach als chinese virus bezeichnet um immer wieder klarzumachen kommt aus china konform feind kommt von den,
dreckig schürt natürlich genauso weiter diese diese ressentiments und diese feindlichkeit ich glaube es wird genau ins umgekehrte gehen dass sie mich jetzt irgendwie,
grenzschließungen wird applaudiert und.
Die werden auch weiter zunehmend auf eine gewisse weise an einigen stellen haben sie sicherlich auch ihre notwendigkeit aber das,
das jetzt auf einmal alle sagen oh lass uns mal mit dem rassismus und der diskriminierung aufhören weil wir sind ja alle als menschen von diesem virus bedroht der glaube ich wird genau der gegenteilige effekt eintreten.
Ich bin da auch nicht ganz so optimistisch weil ähnlich wie bei der klimawandel das ist ein globales
wir sehen aber hier insbesondere dass wir nur nationale lösungen dafür haben
dass das überhaupt keine super nationale koordination stattfindet ich verweis darauf vor ein paar wochen hat italien hilfe besuchern die eu gestellt es gibt da eigene,
dafür wenn ein eu-mitgliedsland in einer besonderen notsituation ist es ging damals um medical surprise also krankenhaus equipment und so.
Und kein einziges eu-land ist ihm gefolgt und die einzige reaktion die wir bisher der eu gesehen haben war kein zu schließen.
Also da ist auch irgendwie klar die haben im moment alle alle kochen gerade nur mit wasser keine hatten ausgefeilten plan.
Es gibt irgendwie dinge wo die wissenschaft indiziert ja einfach schaut dass du die ausbreitung verlangen samst,
daran halten sich auch zunehmend die länder sogar großbritannien nach einer anfänglichen überlegungsphase aber es gibt diesen masterplan nicht das es gibt jetzt niemanden der sagt okay das sind die schritte.
Und wenn du die setzt hört's auf oder so lange wird es dauern es gibt jetzt modellrechnungen aber das sind halt modelle die auch nur gewissen annahmen folgen.
Insofern ist es einfach eine super große herausforderung die wir auf jeden fall nur gemeinsam lösen können,
wenn es irgendwie ein fall gibt wo globale kooperation essentiell ist dann ist es das hier.
Alle können was tun natürlich im rahmen ihrer möglichkeiten aber zumindest zuhause bleiben so gut es geht.
Und solidarisch sein so gut es geht es auf jeden fall geboten.
Klar also es ich habe nicht gesagt es ist jetzt schon so sondern es wird jetzt allen klar dass es so sein muss das ist der wake-up-call,
und.
Das so kommen wird da lasse ich mich gerne in der zukunft dran messen aber ich habe einfach den den eindruck dass es dass das gebälk jetzt einfach anfängt zu knarzen und dass sich,
dementsprechend die handlungen auch entsprechend anpassen werden.
Ja und da ich meine wo man schon noch so sieht ich meine die die wie sehr wir vorbereitet sind auf solche sachen also gerade usa
haben halt einfach ein extrem schlechtes gesundheitssystem oder ein extrem
unzugänglichen teures und das fehlt ihnen jetzt hier auf dem kopf ähnlich wie in großbritannien die ja auch gerade extrem viele forderungen der labour partei von jeremy corbyn aufgreifen weil sie einfach sinn okay müssen eigentlich gerade in diesen dingen,
dieses wirtschaftssituation sind aber auch eben beim gesundheitssystem investieren und dort nicht sparen
das das hinzu glaube ich die ersten maßnahmen die wir zieht und ich find's auch super spannend was ist kulturell mit uns machen wird ob der handschlag überhaupt überleben wird oder ob wir jetzt irgendwie mit ellenbogen uns größen werden oder wie der österreichische bundespräsident macht so irgendwie mit
asiatischen gruß hauptsächlich damit die leute auch mal lachen können dazwischen also ja interesting times.
Ja ja jetzt die frage wird es unsere unsere unsere kulturelle ausrichtung hier groß beeinflussen oder reden wir noch über netzpolitische aspekte der zeit minus.
Wir reden über sehr viel netzpolitische aspekte ich würde vorschlagen wir reden aber als allererstes nochmal ein bisschen über das feedback zur letzten sendungen.
Sie haben.
Erstens relativ viel feedback bekommen zu dem teil über depressionen und depressionen vorsorge das hat mich sehr gefreut das war nämlich sehr positives feedback.
Und dann haben wir noch ich hatte ja um ergänzungen gebeten da kam eine.
Ergänzung von dora bell die sagt also achtung sport in der quarantänezeit sinnvoll ist es auch neben eigengewicht es übungen also.
Hier kniebeugen und handstand und flickflack und was man dann so morgens macht ne ein paar hanteln zu benutzen,
das beugt muskel und knochenabbau vor wer sich keine hanteln anschaffen will kann wasserflaschen befüllen oder nutzt die klopapier vorräte
wer nicht raus darf kann überlegen vitamin d drei zu supplementieren das mache ich ohnehin empfiehlt sich in der winterzeit sowieso bevor ihr das jetzt heute das braucht man nicht so viel von.
Um das zu bilden brauchen wir sonne und erreichen die fenster nicht zurecht dass es ein zu erwarten da zu erwarten der mangel der eintritt wenn man zu lange drin ist oder zu wenig an die sonne kommt und füttern zu so winterdepression
lüften lüften lüften mehrmals täglich ja liebe nerds ne ihr wisst ja.
Rausgehen ist wie fenster auf nur krasser aber fenster offen muss auch manchmal sein.
Hat noch einen anderen hintergrund das mit dem lüften führt natürlich auch dazu dass man die trockene luft in der wohnung abbaut die halt so ein haupt
grund auch dafür ist dass die einer der gründe sind warum es viren im winter einfacher zu haben scheinen sich auszubreiten.
Also generell einfach lüften sehr gute idee.
Bei akuter erkrankung hat sich gezeigt dass die höchste viruslast im schlaf und badezimmer ist hier also nach möglichkeit öfter reinigen und textilien waschen normales putz oder waschmittel reicht
für die lieferantin könnte man im gesunden zustand schon etwas kleingeld in eine büchse oder plastiktüten stellen sodass sie sich das geld dann hygienisch
entnehmen können oder man lässt sich deren paypal adresse geben ja also lieferantin im gastronomiebereich ist jetzt ein großes thema oder geht,
oder wenn es jetzt hier um trinkgeld geht gibt für die leute die gerade noch pakete austragen in riesigen mengen decke da ist es auch.
Vorzusorgen dann.
Hat der politik beobachter schon im prinzip das thema für die heutige sendung gesetzt und sagt der podcast heißt ja netzpolitik zeichnet sich weltweit ab.
Dass sich durch die schutzmaßnahmen im rahmen der krone krise politische partizipation erschwert veranstaltungen fallen aus dem muss dürfen nicht stattfinden.
Auf welche diskussion hat das auswirkungen müssten da nicht auch die konsultationsprozess verlängert werden,
um ein faires verfahren zu ermöglichen wäre es nicht die beste zeit für das verstecken von fiesen entscheidungen sie zum beispiel israel und südkorea ja genau das wollen wir heute besprechen insofern.
Danke politik beobachter genau erkannt was wir was die diese themenbereich für uns bedeutet und dann kommentierte,
fred vom jupiter ich finde ja karin mödling und wolfgang wo da ganz interessant zu korona,
scheint erfahrene wissenschaftlerinnen oder viro login ohne eigeninteresse an dem halb zu sein für mich erstmal überzeugend oder ich habe dann auf den.
Er war dann so eine webseite mit achtundvierzig verschiedenen schriftfarben und schriftgrößen.
Wo jetzt irgendwelche nie zuvor gehörte stimmen gesammelt werden oder aus gutem grund nie zuvor gehörte stimmen gehört werden die jetzt irgendwie ja wilde verschwörungstheorien um diese.
Krise entwickeln dass das halt alles völlig übertrieben sei und da gibt's doch da doch irgendjemand ein interesse daran dass das jetzt irgendwie zur krise,
hoch geredet wird und so ich habe so einen persönlich so ein vorsichtigen einfachen test so wenn jemand irgendwie mehr als vier schriftgrößen und fünf farben bei seinen schriften braucht dann,
kann das meistens ist es dann ein luna tick und ich kann nur ernsthaft davor warnen sich jetzt irgendwelche.
Spinner anzugucken die auf irgendwelchen die von irgendwelchen ehemaligen rtl nachrichten moderatorinnen im wohnzimmer interviewt werden.
Das in der letzten sendung schon gesagt es gibt in deutschland,
neben einigen sehr schwarzen schafen dann doch eine seriöse medienlandschaft,
darum bemüht ist seriös aufzuklären wir haben schon diesen podcast mit dem christian droste,
empfohlen dass es,
nach wie vor pflichtprogramm weil er mir langsam auch so ein bisschen pontius pilatus mäßig wird und häufig so seine hände meint in in unschuld zu waschen.
Irgendwie zu sagen so ja ich kann ja hier nicht die maßnahmen alleine empfehlen und so also ich persönlich bin inzwischen an dem punkt dass.
Radikaleren maßnahmen der isolation notwendig werden weil was so viele menschen.
Offenbar also wenn ich mir eins wünschen will dass leute vielleicht in dieser situation lernen dann ist das exponentiell rechnung ja da haben menschen seit jeher ein problem mit.
Und es wäre schön wenn da mal langsam sich etwas ergeben würde ich gebe aber auch zu die.
Wirtschaftlichen schäden die jetzt entstehen finde ich inzwischen beängstigender als der die bedrohung durch.
Das virus also da gibt es ein aspekt den ich vorher nicht so.
Also den ich anfangs weniger stark berücksichtigt habe oder persönlich weniger stark berüchtigt habe dass ich halt,
eigentlich an dem punkt war okay so schnell wie möglich ein shutdown machen um so schnell wie möglich die infektion verwalter verbreitung einzuschränken und vielleicht.
Das virus noch auszurotten oder unter kontrolle zu bekommen.
In so einem bereich wie man das jetzt mit ebola oder anderen bieren ja durchaus geschafft hat in in verschiedenen ländern dieses planeten oder in verschiedenen kontinenten sogar.
Inzwischen wenn man sich anschaut was hier so an den märkten los ist und welche unternehmen alle in bedrohungslagen sind dann sieht das noch.
Natürlich so aus dass man sich fragen kann ob nicht.
Einige dieser maßnahmen unter umständen tatsächlich das kind mit dem mit dem bade ausgießen also ich sehe jetzt in berlin die berliner klubkultur die sind alle geschlossen das sind natürlich alles.
Kollektive oder unternehmungen mit laufenden mietverträgen den laufenden personalkosten und jetzt schlag auf schlag null einkommen auf unbestimmte zeit da geht's natürlich,
sofort in die an die existenz des gastronomie und kneipen da geht's natürlich weiter da wird man sich jetzt ernsthafte
lösung einfallen lassen müssen gibt ja jetzt zum beispiel dieses united stream,
das große berliner klubkultur die dann irgendwie aus den aus den jeweiligen läden aus den lehren läden livestream mit mit auflegen und da irgendwie um spenden.
Bitten sehe die kneipen.
Die jetzt so trinke ein virtuelles bier bei uns spendet geld damit wir irgendwie den mietvertrag wenigstens halten können oder sowas da wird's
da sind natürlich jetzt schon krasse schäden die wenn man sich wenn man dem die weltweiten inflationsraten zum zeitpunkt jetzt
gegenüber hält zunächst einmal übertrieben erscheinen
insofern kann ich verstehen dass ich dann hier für irgendwelche weniger informierten also nicht ganz so informationsapp viro login.
Die möglichkeit bietet ja.
Irgendwelchen quatsch zu reden ja und ich denke aber schon dass es sinnvoller ist sich hier an leute mit ein bisschen credentials zu halten wie.
Beispielsweise den christian droste oder eben auch die angela merkel oder sogar und jetzt jetzt jetzt bei mir langsam das fieber ein jens spahn.
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht dass ja.
Da würde ich gerne anfangen also ich ich kann nicht alles teilen was du gerade gesagt hast ich würde ich glaube man kann die krisen nicht gegeneinander aufwiegen.
Musst du aber.
Was aber wo ich dir absolut zustimmen ist
dass wir jetzt auch in der wirtschaftskrise reinschlittern werden wegen dem was gerade passiert und die frage ist halt von welcher wirtschaft sprechen wir hier die beispiele die du genannt hast ganz klar also ich glaube da muss ein
ein rettungspaket her ähnlich der bankenrettung damals wo wirklich die die die.
Die kompletten geldreserve auch mal frei gemacht werden um diese ganzen existenzen die gerade.
In dieser situation zu grunde gehen und aufzufangen und dann möglichst vielen menschen einfach noch ein einkommen zu ermöglichen und auch zu schauen dass die betriebe und vor allem eben auch die physischen jetzt nicht on mars über die krippe springen.
Auf der auf der anderen seite hast du irgendwie das was in der virtuellen wirtschaft also in in den aktienmärkten gerade passiert das ist ja auch irgendwie,
mehr als kammerflimmern was da passiert und das zu beobachten es ist auch horst spannend gerade und gleichzeitig,
da hat sich glaube ich auch noch keine klare meinung gebildet welche richtung es geht jetzt gerade wo wir aufnehmen
wieder gerade das in den usa die futures wieder nach oben gehen also das auch kurskorrekturen wieder nach oben stattfinden ich glaube inflation oder insgesamt also fragen der unterschiede in den fertigkeiten des geldes das wird jetzt glaube ich,
was uns auf die füße fallen könnte und ich hoffe einfach dass die politik bei der lokalen wirtschaft jetzt.
Mit ausreichend geld unterstützend eingreift sodass das abgefedert werden kann.
Also klar alles richtige probleme für die man dann auch entsprechende maßnahmen noch aufrufen muss ne also,
jetzt droht vor allem vielen die kündigung da sage ich.
Kündigungsfrist wirklichkeit einfach aussetzen sollten einfach alle mietverträge eingefroren werden und darf nichts gekündigt werden bis hin zu alle mieten.
Die also sozusagen also schon gar nicht durch den ausfall von mietzahlungen.
Ja aber auch ansonsten nicht nicht dass ich jetzt sozusagen leute die schon irgendjemand schon immer mal raushaben wollten die gelegenheit nutzen das steht natürlich zu befürchten insbesondere was so
clubszene begehrlichen locations in der stadt etcetera betrifft da haben natürlich leute mit viel geld längeren atem und es nummer auch die leute denen
das eigentum in der regel gehört ich gehe davon aus dass wir sowas sehen werden.
Also das wäre wir werden uns mit dem mit der wirtschaft der krise nochmal in einer anderen sendung genauer auseinandersetzen aber naiv würde ich auch
ehrlich gesagt glauben dass es am sinnvollsten wäre jetzt bei den bei den mieten anzusetzen weil wenn wir mal ganz ehrlich sind,
mieteinnahmen sind kapitaleinkommen das heißt wer mieteinnahmen hat hat genug ja und ich denke dass hier eher geschützt werden muss wer einnahmen aus aus tätigkeit hat.
Und da wäre es natürlich eine sehr sympathische möglichkeit zum beispiel zu sagen okay mieten in dieser zeit mietausfälle in der zeit werden.
Werden halt toleriert ja du kannst jetzt nicht kündigen weil du nicht miete gezahlt hast und die mieten werden halt mal gedeckelt zack und wer dann da deshalb
kommen wir dann immer hunger wir haben aber kredit aufgenommen um diese mieteinnahmen zu haben ja gut dann werden diese kredite eben jetzt pausiert
ja denn dann wird wird dieser teil pausiert und ausgesetzt weil das ist nämlich das was,
bleibt ja also wenn du jetzt irgendwie wohnung irgendwelche irgendwelche immobilien hast und die vermietet die wir es ja so schnell nicht verlieren
während ein paar monate ohne arbeit ich eben sofort ruinieren und auf die straße setzen also da.
Könnte man ansetzen aber dem thema werden wir uns.
Noch ein bisschen mehr nähern jetzt ging's ja in dem kommentar erstmal darum dass jetzt irgendwelche.
Also es gibt immer egal was ist hast du spinner die ist halt vollständig übertreiben und spinner dieses vollständig herunterspielen ich erkenne auch genug leute oder wenn du jetzt irgendwie hier in diese wenn du dir diese rechte
szene oder in diese szene schaust die jetzt irgendwie nah in in in massen sich auf den.
Zusammenbruch der zivilisation vorbereiten auch das wird nicht unbedingt so so schnell passieren aber genauso ist es unverantwortlich sich jetzt sich jetzt hier diese diese risiken.
Vollständig herunterzuspielen und zeugt eben letztendlich nur davon dass der gute herr eben in exponentiell rechnung nicht so viel ahnung hat in typografie und.
Gestaltung auch nicht und da sollte er vielleicht erstmal ein bisschen nacharbeiten ein thema wir haben's jetzt gerade schon angesprochen was für uns ein bisschen.
Oder was jetzt problematisch ist videokonferenzen ich habe da
mir mal in den letzten tagen die den spaß gemacht oder die die aufgabe gesetzt ein paar videokonferenz server aufzusetzen und zwar mit gisi das geht,
relativ simpel kann man sich so ein server aufsetzen funktioniert dann und dann habe ich gestern mal zwei dieser server.
Getwittert die waren dann natürlich auch sofort.
Überlastet dann hat es hatte ich relativ viele leute auf diesen servern die sie nutzen wollten und interessanterweise nachfragen von.
Therapeutinnen und therapeuten und dann durfte ich eintauchen in die interessante welt der fernthermometer pie,
weil einerseits sich sehr viele also einige bei mir im meldeten und sagten hier kann ich das eben kann ich darüber meine therapiestunden abhalten würde ich so denke ja klar die server loggen nichts die verbindung sind verschlüsselt kann ich guten gewissens den leuten empfehlen,
dann kam aber natürlich sofort die ja.
Die fraktion die sagte nein keinesfalls die anbieter mit über die man solche therapie therapie nutzt müssen,
irgendwie zertifiziert sein von der bvb und jetzt verlierst du deine approbation und kannst das nicht abrechnen werde das über irgendwie ein komplett daten sparsam server von linus machst und.
Da habe ich mir dann auch gedacht ja gut dass wir in deutschland sind wo wo solche sachen dann geregelt werden also das ist.
Sehr schön zu beobachten wie jetzt auch so.
Eine reihe an regeln die die man sich eben in zeichen zeiten des friedens setzt um irgendwie was gutes zu erreichen natürlich komplett.
In solchen phasen
in die in die tonne gehen und dann eben der pragmatismus der krise nicht gegeben ist der diese zertifizierten anbieter die haben natürlich ein monopol artige positionen die haben ihre server jetzt gerade nicht im griff die therapeutinnen und therapeuten weichen aus auf skype
ja
super aber wenn dann jemand sagt hier guck mal ich habe daten sparsame server aufgesetzt auf für mein geld die ich euch kostenlos zur verfügung stelle dann wird da wird da drauf gehauen.
Aber ich habe zumindest persönlich daraus die die die lehre gezogen ja ich bin jetzt auch nicht unbedingt dafür verantwortlich die fehlenden kapazitäten dieser kommerziellen anbieter aufzufordern die damit geld verdienen und.
Freue mich dass aber auch viele meinem beispiel gefolgt sind und noch sehr viel potential und sehr viel mehr server aufgesetzt haben zum beispiel hat der tiefster noch mit gitzi punkt rocks direkt eine,
gitzi server farben aufgesetzt und die können ja die menschen nutzen kann ich kann ich empfehlen.
Kommen wir weiter nachbarschaftshilfe linus.
Insgesamt zeigt sich jetzt eben eine zeit in der viele menschen.
Einander helfen ne also das geht ja los vom musikunterricht therapie und anderen dingen die über die ferne.
Irgendwie passieren können wir haben uns in der letzten sendung ja auch schon angesprochen es ist jetzt zeit ja auch mal vielleicht mit den nachbarn zu sprechen ob er den beim einkauf helfen kann und sonstige sachen und.
Da gibt's jetzt auch einen hecke von wir versus virus der beginnt heute also heute am freitag.
Wo die bundesregierung kreative lösungen für die kurve zeit sucht also interessierte bürgerinnen und bürger sowie interessierte akteure können ihre ideen einreichen.
Man kann sich dort als teilnehmende registrieren oder als patin oder mentorin patin sind leute die quasi eine idee haben und deren realisierung also quasi die.
Product owner mentorinnen helfen den teilnehmern denn dabei irgendwie.
Beraten die irgendwie die sachen besser hinzukriegen in den virtuellen gruppen und alle sind eingeladen mitzumachen finde ich jetzt mal also solche initiativen sind ja auch so ein bisschen das was solche zeiten dann auch interessant macht ja wo.
Eben auch neue herausforderungen entstehen und ein.
Gefühl zu zu etwas beizutragen und nicht alles muss ja dann am ende so entmutigend laufen wie mein bereitstellen von videos servern ich freue mich ja wenn leute die nutzen und ich freue mich wenn andere damit machen seit ein bisschen.
Traurig wenn es dann an irgendwelchen regularien meint zu scheitern wobei ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt
sagen kann da waren die therapeutinnen mit denen ich gesprochen habe dann schon etwas pragmatischer vielleicht als die bedenkenträger.
Wie so oft.
Zu diesem server nochmal ich ich ich weiß nicht aber in meinem kopf was irgendwo da ist es jetzt gerade so schatzi server sind so wie eva instanzen
wer kennt das ist so ein ein tool zur kollaborativen textverarbeitung über das halt sehr oft eben vom protokollen über gemeinsame
schularbeiten und alles irgendwie gemeinsam geschrieben und geteilt wird und so irgendwie sind auch tschüssi server finde ich gerade also die urls werden herumgereicht und das ist auch ein teil oft sind diese server offen.
Und
das ist ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es wirklich ende zu ende verschlüsselt ist aber schon allein dadurch dass es dezentral ist ist schon ein gewisser,
schutz würde ich fast sagen gegeben und die alternative zu chizi wenn man das wieder auf text umlegt.
Die zentralisierte instanz wo
google mitglied das ist summ summ ist auch gerade sehr stark im kommerziellen bereich verbreitet hat gerade einen riesigen boom alle verwenden zoom und wenn man da aber auch näher hinschickt wir werden einen artikel verlinken die haben auch massive.
Schutzprogramm e und ihre praxis ist so dass da auch die daten an dritte weitergegeben werden und,
insofern an der stelle nur der kleine tipp das natürlich auch bei der wahl eines videokonferenz systems solche fragen eine rolle spielen.
Kurz zu es gibt eigentlich kaum,
vernünftig funktionierende videokonferenz systeme die peer-to-peer und ende zu ende verschlüsselt sind weil es also in im strengsten sinne weil wenn das jetzt
also wenn du wirklich von einer ende zu ende verschlüsselung ausgehen würdest müsstest du ja vielleicht auch an jeden einzelnen deiner kommunikationspartner ein anders,
verschlüsselten stream senden,
deswegen handeln diese systeme in der regel irgendwie einen schlüssel aus oder replizieren den street bei der nutzung von gisi vertraut ihr,
de facto den server betreibenden also der server selber könnte dafür sorgen dass der stream auf eine weise verschlüsselt ist dass er für den server abgreifbar ist und deswegen ist das eben,
sinnvoll sich so ein ding einfach selber hochzuschießen und es ist tatsächlich mit wenigen befehlen auf irgendeiner büchse getan und da kann man sich für eine kleine mag irgendein.
Server klicken und einfach seine eigenen server da drauf ziehen und da seine eigenen meetings drauf machen das ist tatsächlich eine eine sehr sehr schnell zu erledigende aufgabe für diejenigen die es nicht.
So spontan können haben sich eben jetzt viele leute bereit erklärt einfach mal solche instanzen hochzuziehen.
Cool sollen wir weitermachen ich hätte irgendwie glaube ich sowas vielleicht hilfreich ist
ist mal makroskopisch über die die aktuelle situation drüber zu schauen und das haben wir also bei bisher gemacht
und eine reihe an empfehlungen abgegeben aus netz politischer sicht was die aktuelle lage für uns bedeutet.
Und
der versuch ist da einfach auch mal aufzuzeigen womit wir uns konfrontieren müssen es sind ein paar empfehlungen drin aber es ist auch einfach so mindful of the oder,
das was jetzt wahrscheinlich auch noch bei vielen thema sein wird und schon diskutiert wurde ist soeben die ganzen notfallmaßnahme die jetzt kommen.
Da werden wir ganz viel sehen gerade in asien wurden ja auch viele maßnahmen schon gesetzt.
Unsere empfehlung ist dass gerade in so einer zeit wo.
Der staat auch nicht nur die funktion hat gesetze zu machen sondern auch den leitenden bisschen vorzugeben wie zu leben ist
das staatliche handeln extrem transparent und verantwortungsvoll sein muss und eben jetzt irgendwelche sinnlosen überwachungs- gesetze oder aushebeln von grundrechten wer wirklich tödlich
weil einfach dann also wir können im moment gerade nicht demonstrieren
oder zumindest wäre es sehr schwierig eine demo abzuhalten wo alle den ein meter sicherheitsabstand voneinander einhalten
was auch heißt unsere möglichkeiten der politischen beteiligung sind stark eingeschränkt.
Eine empfehlung von uns wäre deswegen dass man auf online partizipation möglichkeiten umstellt also dass da jetzt gerade auch die zeit gekommen ist für für vielleicht auch neue werkzeuge oder die die es schon gibt
ordentlich einzusetzen und das kann man auf allen ebenen machen also von kommunaler angefangen,
ganz wichtig ist aus unserer sicht dass die die information weiterfließen kann das heißt mal irgendwie open data was die konkreten fallzahlen
betrifft möglichst fein granular bis auf bezirksebene damit wir uns einfach gemeinsam bild
machen können aufgrund der ist-situation
in manchen ländern gibt solche open data plattformen schon ich glaube in deutschland sind es noch pdfs aber wahrscheinlich hat gibt's die in irgendwelchen open data eis die ich nicht kenne in dem fall postet die bitte in den kommentaren,
und eine eine weitere empfehlung ist dass artikel zu der krise.
Doch bitte von boys zu befreien sind weil gerade da wo diese wichtige information von von medien kommt sollte die jetzt nicht nur für die abonnenten zur verfügung stehen sondern für alle menschen ganz einfach
an selbiges gilt für öffentlich-rechtliche inhalte da haben deutschland und österreicher dieselbe situation dass mutwillig die inhalte die wir alle mit steuergeld
bezahlt haben nach sieben tagen die publiziert werden und ich glaube es ist auch ganz klar dass in der jetzigen situation so eine depo publikation,
sehr sinnlos ist schädlich ist und deswegen einfach abgeschafft werden soll und das würde nicht viel brauchen nicht viel kosten und wer schnell geschehen
und.
Ein ganz wichtiger punkt ist aber auch dass man überhaupt zu diesen informationen kommt wir werden nachher noch über netzneutralität als solches reden aber.
Beschränkungen im datenvolumen also monatliche datenvolumen haben
im moment jetzt wirklich eine sehr schädliche wirkung weil grade wenn menschen homeoffice machen oder schulpflichtige kinder und jugendliche e-learning machen
dann ist natürlich das datenvolumen in windeseile aufgebraucht und ich kenne die zahlen in österreich da ist es
weniger als die hälfte also weniger als die hälfte der menschen hat einen festnetz internetanschluss
das heißt die haben eigentlich nur irgendwelche mobilfunkverträge und die sind in den allermeisten fällen keine flatrates sondern die haben einen monatlichen data cup und wenn der erreicht wird dann ist es schwierig,
und deswegen unsere forderung dass man diese datenvolumen komplett aufhebt in dieser zeit und,
ja zuletzt auch noch irgendwie die frage wie wir mit wahlen umgehen wir haben im moment natürlich also es gab in,
ich glaube in bayern und in frankreich zuletzt noch wahlen in in österreich wurden die in der steiermark und vorarlberg abgesagt aufgrund der krise.
Und wer weiß wie lange das so sein wird und deswegen ist damit zu rechnen dass die rufe nach voting wieder lauter werden.
Darauf müssen wir uns einstellen und ich fände es auch unter dieser maßgabe komplett unverantwortlich eine wahl.
Elektronisch oder erst recht übers internet abzuhalten man kann irgendwie optionen mit briefwahl diskutieren aber.
Wirklich nachvollziehbar für die breite masse ist auch das wahrscheinlich nicht und deswegen ja kann man eigentlich nur mit anderen beteiligungsform vielleicht auch direkt-demokratischen aushelfen.
Aus der alltagsperspektive noch
zwei punkte das eine ist natürlich heute sollte vielen menschen klar sein wieso wir seit so vielen jahren für die eprivacy-verordnung für die datenschutzgrundverordnung
gekämpft haben weil jetzt für das gesamte leben online stattfindet darf aber nicht das gesamte leben überwacht werden und das ist leider gerade im bereich online-tracking heute der fall,
es wäre sinnvoll wenn man das jetzt auch als wake-up-call verwendet um einfach sich nochmal gedanken zu machen was von meinen.
Gesprächen im familien oder freundeskreis ist jetzt gerade eigentlich privat und was kann mitgehört werden welches businessmeeting dass ich jetzt über zoom machen wer kriegt jetzt eigentlich gerade die teilnehmerliste von unserem.
Oder die aufzeichnung davon
an ich glaube diese fragen stellen sich jetzt gerade mehr menschen und dadurch werden auch diese ganzen datenschutz und privacy themen schon auf der konsumentinnen ebene sehr wichtig und zuletzt wäre bei unserem blog vorbeischaut findet auch ein paar anleitungen,
leider nur für österreichisches recht wie es mit urheberrecht ausschaut wenn man online-partys macht und einfach so jetzt irgendwie wenn man
ich habe das am samstag vor über so eine videokonferenz schaltung ein paar leute zusammen holt und dort dann auch,
gemeinsam was trinkt und vielleicht auch musik spielt und in österreich kann man da auf jeden fall entwarnung geben solange diese party nicht öffentlich ist also der link irgendwie nur im freundeskreis geteilt wird ist es egal
wenn da was da für musik gespielt wird und wenn es ein livestream ist dann kann auch kein uploadfilter greifen weil diese upload-filter auch die von google
nur bei aufzeichnungen funktionieren und nicht mehr livestreams.
Das sind alles sehr extrem gute punkte die du da aufzählst das ist in der tat.
Wichtig kann das nur kann das nur unterstützen insbesondere
denke ich mal diese diskussion die werden wir tatsächlich bekommen machen wir uns nichts vor das wird wahrscheinlich relativ schnell gehen und da muss man natürlich echt dagegen halten die frage ist natürlich in so einer geschichte auch immer was,
wie stark man in diese diskussion ein weil man ja natürlich mit einer reinen verweigerungshaltung schnell probleme bekommt.
So nach dem motto wird es eine besondere zeiten lalala man kann sich jetzt nicht an bürokratischen hürden oder an rechtlichen hürden sowas kommt ja auch sehr schnell aufhalten lassen man relativ klar kommuniziert auch eine wahl.
Ist letztlich durchführbar das dauert dann vielleicht länger.
Ja wenn alle zuhause sind aber man kann halt auch sagen die wahl dauert dann halt einfach mal fünf tage muss ja nicht
muss ja nicht im selben rahmen laufen muss ja nicht an einem tag sein man kann ja die stimmzettel auch über einen längeren zeitraum hinweg machen und man kann wahllokale auch eins nach dem anderen aufmachen man muss nicht unbedingt so die mega aktion machen und dann findet
ich finde es halt einfach länger statt und dann kann man das eben auch kontrolliert
machen es ist ja nicht das problem dass man rausgeht es ist ja nur das problem dass man anderen zu nahe kommt und das muss man sollte man ja sozusagen im wahllokal sowieso nicht tun.
Also im prinzip ist ja so das verhalten das typische oder das angemessene verhalten in einem wahllokal entspricht ziemlich genau dem angemessenen verhalten was man jetzt so in diesem virus zeiten auch an den tag legen sollte also man
läuft nicht die anderen leuten hinterher da in ihrem in ihrer wahlkampf und schaut von hinten irgendwie rein.
Das das passt eigentlich ganz gut zusammen und was die daten volumina betrifft vielleicht auch nochmal was dazu auch das kann ich nur voll unterstützen also das.
Im prinzip müsste betrifft ja nicht nur die mobilfunk betrifft ja teilweise eben auch noch festnetzanschluss.
Das muss jetzt einfach mal komplett beendet werden.
Also wenn ich da ganz kurz.
Den aktuellen stand der debatte beibringen darf die datenvolumen in deutschland wurden schon erhöht da kämen wir dann gleich zu aber zu der fern.
Zu der zu der fernen wahl das problem tritt jetzt quasi schon früher ein nämlich auf ebene der eu,
die denken sich natürlich okay wollen wir jetzt hier unsere ganzen alten risiko kandidaten die im europaparlament sitzen hier regelmäßig zu abstimmungen,
versammeln.
Oder setzen wir ein remote wahlsystem ein und die sind quasi gerade dabei das zu tun die haben ja ohnehin schon ein elektronisches wahlsystem ja mit ihren knöpfen die sie da drücken müssen.
Und jetzt denke ich tatsächlich,
wo du wenn du jetzt im eu-parlament so eine abstimmung hast und die sagen okay aus sicherheitsgründen machen wir die jetzt remote.
Dann ist das halt schwierig jetzt dagegen zu argumentieren ja und ich denke die einzigen forderungen die man hier jetzt noch.
Platzieren kann oder die der die notwendig sind sind erstens zu sagen okay das muss,
so sicher wie möglich sein also was weiß ich mit ihrem mit smartcar abgesichert oder sonstigen also nicht so dass die
parlamentarier drinnen sich irgendwie auf irgendeine webseite einloggen oder dann irgendwie in ihrer büro unterstützung sagen hör mal denkst du heute abend noch dran
die abstimmung mitzumachen das muss also irgendwie
hardware gesichert sein mit einem sicheren authentifizierung verfahren dass wie die leute ihre stimme abgeben zweitens muss
klar sein dass das nur eine ausnahme ist ja dass man nämlich jetzt nicht sagt wir ändern die geschäftsordnung des parlamentes und erlauben remote online wahlen sondern wir sagen wir machen irgendwie notstands
ausnahme während der zeit dieser krise und diese ausnahme ist dann wieder weg ja das ist ja denke ich das entscheidende bei.
Machen wir uns nichts vor hier werden einige aufweichung den von sicherheitsanforderungen und auch von bürgerrechten stattfinden und die grundsätzliche forderung ist immer zu sagen okay das darf jetzt nur eine ausnahme sein es muss auch dran stehen dass das
wieder vorbei ist ja und natürlich keinesfalls bei irgendwelchen
abstimmungen die der geheimer die eine geheimhaltung erfordern hat da die das,
tatsächlich aktuell ja regelmäßig solche abstimmungen mit ihren mit ihren it-system und ihren knöpfen da machen muss man dann hier tatsächlich natürlich sagen okay.
Ob man das jetzt mit dem technischen system an ort und stelle macht.
Oder über die ferne das einzige was da das einzige was da tatsächlich eine rolle spielt ist sicherzustellen dass auch wirklich die person.
Wählt die als vertreterin in dieses parlament entsendet wurde und zweitens dass auch wirklich.
Da die richtigen ergebnisse übermittelt wurde natürlich muss man das dann eben auch mit komplett,
fangen wir mal mit fordernden prozessen flankieren dass eben nachher die parlametarierinnen verpflichtet sind das öffentliche ergebnis zu prüfen ihre stimme darin zu checken und das,
in einem erneuten hoheitlichen akt zu bestätigen dass sie ihre stimme war ja.
Und dann denke ich wird man hier mein auge zukneifen müssen aber klar wir stehen dann nämlich genau an dieser an dieser gefährlichen.
Mit jedem einzelnen dieser dieser aufweichung die wir die wir jetzt in den nächsten wochen und monaten sehen müssen sie stehen wir immer an so einem präzedenzfall.
Wo wenn die leute nicht verschwinden man nicht ganz klar macht dass es hier eine abschwächung.
Ist die als ausnahmeregelung ist dass wir sehr sehr schnell in so namen.
In so einer regelmäßigkeit sind und dann irgendwie gesagt wird so haben wir auch gemacht war super.
Das muss eben klar sein dass das ausnahmen sind genauso wie so eine bankenrettung die wir wahrscheinlich in zwei monaten wieder machen werden ne was heißt also wer wird jetzt gerettet wahrscheinlich airbus boing
vw banken da muss dann auch wieder klar sein dass das eine ausnahme ist und wie das allenfalls alle fünf bis zehn jahre machen.
Die grundrechte müssen ich werde jetzt nochmal ein bisschen auf den auf eine etwas metall-foundation bringen grundrechte müssen halt aufrecht erhalten bleiben der datenschutz muss jetzt.
Existieren und auch für die zukunft ja es gibt ja jetzt diese ersten zugriffe auf location daten und persönliche daten auch da muss klar sein ausnahme ausnahmen ausnahme.
Und ein punkt den den du den ich in der letzten sendung schon von dir zitiert hatte glaube ich thomas ist.
Wenn da jetzt daten zugriffe stattfinden muss der anwendungszeit weck begrenzt werden ja wo also klar also anwendungszeit zweck und zeitraum bei solchen zugriffsmaßnahmen muss ganz klar eingeschränkt und reguliert werden ja und eben nicht.
Irgendwelche wirklichen dauerhaften gesetzesänderungen die das ganze zum prozess machen sondern eben,
ausnahme erlasse mit definierten zwecken mit definierten zeiträumen die dafür sorgen dass alle diese einschränkung und und ausnahmen und so weiter.
Temporärer natur sind das ganze muss transparent stattfinden und unter öffentlicher kontrolle sein.
Rassismus und diskriminierung haben wir genug brauchen wir nicht noch mehr und entsprechend denke ich wird man hier.
Auch zeigen können ja wir befinden uns eben in einem.
Notstand dann handeln wir aber bitte auch so ja und sorgen dafür dass wir wenn wir diesen notstand überstanden haben wir eben nicht eine reihe an an bürgerrechten
und menschenrechten und grundrechten irgendwie über bord geworfen haben die wir jetzt dauerhaft verloren haben ich denke das wird hier die,
ja die verteidigungslinie sein auf die jetzt zu achten ist.
Ja absolut also es gibt es gibt zwei gefahren die wir als netzpolitische zivilgesellschaft jetzt auf dem radar haben müssen einerseits das
mit der krise dinge argumentiert und gerechtfertigt werden die sonst nie durchgehen würden am set wirklich die art wie man darüber nachdenken muss ja
hilft diese maßnahme wirklich dabei dieser dieser krise bei zu
kommen und wenn wenn das der fall ist müssen immer noch ganz spezifische drinnen sein die gesetze brauchen ein ablaufdatum eines sunset klaus wie du gesagt hast ganz spezifischen zweck geben dafür und dann,
kann aber eine reihe maßnahmen verhältnismäßig sein die wir sonst nie als verhältnismäßig durchgehen hätten,
lassen und dass das ist was wir in österreich auch schon,
tun müssten in einer verschärfung die am wochenende beschlossen wurde wo wir uns auch schon mit einer juristischen analyse geäußert haben das ist die erste gefahr die zweite gefahr ist dass jetzt eine menge an gesetzen so im im versteckten,
beschlossen wird wo die ganzen medienberichterstattung sich nur um dieses eine thema kümmert kann man auch wunderbar andere dinge noch im hintergrund verstecken.
Da muss man auch ein ganz genaues auge drauf haben was jetzt durch die parlamente gepachtet welche verordnungen auch von den ministerien erlassen werden also da ist zivilgesellschaft weiterhin extrem gefordert
weil wie gesagt wenn man kann als staat hier mit besonderem handeln sehr viel,
vertrauen in der bevölkerung gewinnen man kann es aber noch viel schneller verlieren wenn man unverantwortlich handelt.
Immerhin wir haben aber auch eine gute nachricht teilweise eine gute nachricht und zwar haben sich zumindest einige der bekannteren
gruppen.
Bereit erklärt auf angriffe auf krankenhäuser in zeiten der krise zu verzichten.
Da hat er blieb computer hat eben einige der gangs mal erreicht und angefragt hat gesagt jungs wie sieht's aus bei euch ne hier pflegeeinrichtungen und so während der pandemien wie seht ihr das und da haben.
Eben gesagt so also doppelpack haben gesagt,
wir gehört ohnehin nicht zu unseren zielgruppen ja das heißt wir werden bei unserer politik bleiben oder mails haben dann zum beispiel gesagt sie hatten direkt.
Pressemitteilung gemacht dass sie ihre aktivitäten gegen medizinische einrichtungen bis zum ende der pandemien aussetzen wirklich
schon sehr schön ja wenn die wenn die mafia jetzt auch noch bekannt gibt vielleicht dass sie in zeiten der krise auf die schutzgeld zahlungen verzichtet dann sehen wir doch tatsächlich dass wir hier auch in der solidarität ein bisschen.
Doch zusammenrücken.
Der familie geht es auch um ehre weißt du.
Wobei ich glaube in italien traut sich die mafia auch inzwischen nicht mehr vor die tür das ist ja auch ein bargeld gebundenes gewerbe.
Ja was die mafia jetzt für einnahmeausfälle hat wer wer wer gleich das aus da ist auch der staat gefragt.
Soll ich das überweisen nein nein nein.
Eine eine sehr schöne meldung fand ich übrigens auch.
Jetzt mal über daten und bandbreiten sprechen die den blogpost von einer webseite mit dem namen pornhub von der ich noch nie gehört habe.
Die schreiben,
visite porn hab routine von mord eine million people kürze der täglichen routine diese.
Webseite von privaten privaten schaukel videos da.
Ich wollte gerade sagen.
Und die haben.
Die haben ich glaube das war ja in italien als sie als die krise in italien losging haben sie ja dann gesagt er kommt ihr kriegt alle premium was soll's ne.
Und haben festgestellt dass in italien glaube ich ein zuwachs von siebenundfünfzig prozent zu beobachten war.
Im datenvolumen oder was.
Also ihr genau den traffic den sie in den jeweiligen ländern haben frankreich achten dreißig prozent spanien einundsechzig prozent ja,
ich glaube in spanien sind die leute ein bisschen jünger und ja in deutschland sechs prozent.
Wir haben es in deutschland auch aufgehoben.
Ne da haben sie es noch nicht aufgehoben das ist natürlich hier der konfrontieren der effekt in deutschland gibt es glaube ich noch kein pornhub premium für die massen aber es zeigt halt trotzdem also es deckt sich mit meiner beobachtung dass da draußen immer noch viel zu viele wichser rumlaufen.
Hallo.
Na ja.
Der deko deko hat gesagt sie haben insgesamt seit dem elften märz zehn prozent plus.
Im conference bereich fünfzig prozent mehr im gaming-bereich fünfundzwanzig prozent mehr und einen erheblichen anstieg in social media.
Haben aber dann gesagt dass sie.
Jetzt irgendwie zwanzig prozent ausbau an ihren knoten betreiben denn sie halten grundsätzlich siebenunddreißig prozent reserve über der durchschnittlichen,
also der satz war mir nicht ganz klar ich glaube dem durch den den bedarf also sie haben quasi über der grundlast oder über dem durchschnittlichen peak siebenunddreißig prozent reserve.
Ja oder anders anders ausgedrückt wenn sie bei dreiundsechzig prozent auslastung sind dann bauen sie auf.
Bauen sie weiter genau dann bauen sie weiter und das haben sie jetzt erreicht und machen das jetzt und die.
Schöne diskussion ist natürlich jetzt ok geht denn jetzt unter umständen.
Das ganze porn hab und netflix und so weiter zu lasten.
Des homeoffice e-learning live konferenzen für podcasts und so weiter und da haben jetzt.
Quasi schon die ersten.
Meldungen haben wir jetzt das netflix sagt sie reduzieren ihre bandbreite um fünfundzwanzig prozent in europa für für die nächsten dreißig tage erstmal.
Und ich glaube youtube hat auch gesagt sie schalten jetzt mal das hd ab und ich weiß nicht genau was ich davon halten soll wenn ich mir nämlich die zahlen anhöre vom keks ja.
Dann sieht es ja so aus als hätten wir jetzt erst mal nicht unbedingt ein problem die haben letzte woche ihren rekord gehabt mit neun komma eins terabite davor waren sie irgendwie durchschnittlich bei acht also ja die haben.
Stellen fest geht geht jetzt los sagen aber auch krise welche krise die haben halt reserven da bauen ausläuft.
Wenn ich mir andererseits anschaue welche schwierigkeiten wir gerade hatten unsere videokonferenz hier herzustellen dann,
scheint ist ja schon so zu sein dass in dem fall thomas cable basierter anschluss eben an an sein ende ist und das erscheint mir dann eher ein problem der letzten meile zu sein als ein problem
der der wirklichen backbord infrastruktur die wir hier haben das ist aber jetzt mal so vorsichtig geschätzt.
Ja gut das ist natürlich bei kabel basierten also bei fernsehen kabel basierten anschlüssen grundsätzliches problem weil man sich eben,
die bandbreite lokal schon mit allen anderen anschluss teilnehmern auf dem kabel teilt bevor es überhaupt.
Ja warum hat man die scheiße denn so gebaut.
Das ist halt prinzip bedingt dass es halt eben kabel was für die verbreitung von fernsehen gedacht war und das ist halt.
Medium und was anderes als ein dedizierte anschlusskabel was in jedes haus geht.
Richtig und genau deswegen hätte man diesen mist nicht bauen sollen.
Ja gut der war da.
Ja aber jetzt haben wir ihn.
Der war da und deswegen wurde er jetzt halt mit genutzt und er hat ja im prinzip auch was gebracht.
Der punkt den ich machen möchte ist folgender wenn ich den wenn ich den punkt ganz kurz machen kann.
Wir haben unter umständen jetzt irgendwo auf der letzten meile bandbreiten probleme.
Und jetzt muss netflix die oder youtube die ganz normale dienstleistungen des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts anbieten auch wenn ich.
Persönlich ich denke dass die ideale vermittlung methode für fernsehen ist aber.
Ich glaube dass hier unter umständen die falschen,
geblendet werden wenn man jetzt ausgerechnet den den videostream man sagt ey fahrt mal die qualität und die bandbreite runter weil letztendlich hätten die hätten wir vernünftige netze bauen müssen und wenn wir hier
zeitgemäße netze hätten dann würden wir alle schön mit unseren glasfasern hier netflix und pornhub gucken als tägliche routine.
Also die lösung für fast alle probleme im im reinen netzwerk bereich ist glasfaser ja das ist aber jetzt nicht,
gangbare weg in der aktuellen situation diese frage von netz überlastungen das ist eine die
die mir auch gerade in letzter zeit ganz oft gestellt wird deswegen muss ich auch in einer stunde auf dem interview zum genau zu dem thema wir haben uns das näher angeschaut also als wir damals das netzneutralität gesetz in europa geschrieben haben haben wir explizit eine bestimmung
rein
geben für solche szenarien von drohenden netz überlastungen von von zeitlich beschränkten und außerordentlichen ereignissen das genau solchen situationen dann eben auch,
gedrosselt blockiert an andere sehr drakonischer maßnahmen,
begrüßen werden können also alles was einen netzbetreiber tun kann mehr oder weniger so lange dabei,
gleiche verkehrs klassen gleich behandelt werden also was diese bestimmung und die gilt in ganz europa einheitlich.
Nach der kannst du netflix und youtube drosseln du musst aber auch deine hauseigenen video angebote zum beispiel draußen und du kannst nicht einzelne anbieter rauspicken sondern jeden
in der klasse zum beispiel
videostreaming oder videokonferenz singen oder falsch hering natürlich gibt's dann an einschränkungen wie fast du diese klasse gerade so was wie video also video streams die,
in einer qualität ausgeliefert werden je nachdem wie gut die leitung gerade ist die zu erkennen ist technisch von netz seite gar nicht so einfach.
Deswegen ist das ein thema wo.
Es dann vielleicht trotzdem auch sinn machen kann dass einzelne anbieter von sich aus die qualität reduzieren,
diese diese reaktion aber gerade von netflix war nicht sozusagen von ihnen ausgeschickert sondern.
Breton terry patron der nachfolger von günther oettinger eu digital kommissar hat zuvor die forderung geäußert an netflix doch bitte.
Das europäische internet zu schonen und eben die videoqualität im eigenen dienst zu reduzieren und dieser forderung ist ist netflix da ganz einfach gefolgt und ja im kern.
Wie es vorher ja schon vom vom dezibel gesagt wurde und wie ob wir das auch von
dem wiener internet exchange den wir auch verlinken gehört haben im moment scheint die kapazitäten noch auszuweichen auch die internetbetreiber die gerade vor die kameras treten müssen sagen das aber natürlich könnte es irgendwann jetzt nochmal zu,
überlastungen kommen das mit dem video conference hat sicherlich das entstehen wir sicherlich auch erst am anfang ich glaube dass das auch noch als
anwendung für gesellschaftliche dinge für familiären austausch noch stärker wird
insofern keiner von uns kann es wissen und es wäre gut wenn wir uns auf eine stabile internet-infrastruktur in dieser situation verlassen können.
Ich will nur einfach sagen so an sich wir haben davor gesorgt das sind keine probleme die uns jetzt über rennen sollen,
wenn man individuell was tun kann kann man irgendwie statt vier k video vielleicht auf hd umschalten das wäre vielleicht sinnvoll.
Aber ja ich würde auf jeden fall noch nicht alarmistische werden.
Vielleicht noch eine kurze ergänzung zu dieser perspek
das problem besteht nur auf der letzten meile also es besteht definitiv an der letzten meile aber meiner auffassung nach nicht nur wenn man in deutschland auch die situation
das ist ein ganz großer player an diesem ganzen die zig spaß überhaupt nicht teilnimmt ja wir haben das zwar den großen netz knoten aber der schließt ja die telekom nicht mit ein weil es telekom weil die telekom halt an dort eben nicht peeling mit dem rest deutschlands macht sondern sich eigentlich seit jahren
dahinter versteckt zu sagen ja wir sind hier die größten und wenn ihr mit uns irgendwie was machen wollt dann müsst ihr mit uns halt dedizierte pairing
verträge abschließen was denn.
Auch große anbieter wie hetzen und so weiter mittlerweile in diese situation gezwungen hat ja neulich erst eine mail geschrieben haben gesagt haben so hier naja jetzt,
eingeknickt so wollten wir eigentlich nie aber geht nicht anders und da hätte die telekom ganz andere möglichkeiten
innerhalb der netz verteilung nochmal die bandbreiten zu vereinfachen,
indem sie sich hier halt einfach in eine sinnvolle peeling struktur die ohnehin schon existiert einfach mit einklinkt.
Ja also das ist eine forderung die wir schon ganz lange haben irgendwie mehr transparenz im piercingbereich dass das ist wer jetzt super hilfreich wenn wir diese zahlen hätten
und da sind eben wirklich nur so große platzhirschen dagegen alle anderen sind für transparenz in dieser frage,
von interconnect in der frage wohnt daten zwischen einzelnen netzen ausgetauscht werden,
aber wie gesagt das größere problem was ich eigentlich sehe ist die frage auf der auf der nutzerinnen ebene,
viele menschen haben keine festnetzanschluss die haben handytarife und die sind oft volumens beschränkt und wenn ich jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr nur meinem privaten konsum sondern auch der.
Beruflichen im home-office über mobilfunk machen muss ein österreich ist es so schulen und kindergärten sind geschlossen
außer es ist wirklich notwendig dass die kinder dort betreut werden das heißt fünfundneunzig prozent der kinder sollen jetzt von zu hause aus e-learning machen,
naja das wird mit einer drei gigabyte leitung nicht irgendwie einen monat funktionieren weil dort dort sind audiovisuelle inhalte natürlich besonders sinnvoll wenn ich irgendwie mathematik lernen sollt und
da alleine zuhause dran sitze ist natürlich ein video das mir die grundlagen erklärt besser als wenn ich das nur lesen kann und deswegen ist unsere forderung gerade bei solchen fällen jetzt endlich die datenvolumen freizugeben und in österreich,
haben wir jetzt den ersten betreiber von von einem discounter
der der gefolgt ist und wir hoffen dass noch viel mehr betreiber dem folgen weil das ist jetzt gerade kein internet zu haben ist einfach eine wirklich beschissene situation und es ist gerade vor dem hinblick demokratischer beteiligung wichtig.
Weil wie gesagt wir können nicht demonstrieren gehen vielleicht können wir auch jetzt eine zeit lang nicht wählen gehen
und dann nicht einmal mehr die möglichkeit zu haben im internet an der debatte teilzunehmen halte ich für keine tragbare situation erst recht nicht auf dauer.
Da vielleicht noch ein bisschen kontext bezüglich dieser e-learning situation dein beispiel war ja gerade videos anschauen macht sinn ja klar stimmt macht sinn wird aber.
Ist glaube ich gar nicht mal der der aktivste teil ich habe das ja jetzt mit meinen kids hier ganz ganz klar direkt vor augen wie das läuft das ding ist.
Hier läuft den ganzen tag videokonferenz weil.
Meine kinder mit anderen kindern aus ihrer klasse zusammenhalts aufgaben machen dann geht einfach,
skype was auch immer videoplattform deiner wahl geht an das telefon steht auf dem tisch und die quatschen die ganze zeit miteinander und
betreiben damit natürlich auch ganz wichtige soziale komponente und helfen sich gegeneinander und dadurch macht das lernen auch spaß also mal ganz
unabhängig von irgendwelchen lernvideos videokonferenz muss einfach,
wie die regional möglich sein und da kommen wir natürlich dann auch noch in so einen anderen punkt den ich schon seit immer nervt diese asymmetrische auslegung von von heim anschlüssen.
Das immer alles download download download download ist und über ablade upload redet überhaupt keiner selbst wenn du diese begrenzung nicht hast
im volumen hast du oft eben auch nochmal die
zusätzliche begrenzung bin schon der download nicht passt dass der upload halt überhaupt nicht passt und wenn du dann davon ausgehst dass du drei vier fünf teilnehmer in der wohnung,
hast also an einem anschluss hast familienmitglieder die alle natürlich diesen sozialen bedarf haben die kinder eben noch ein bisschen mehr naja
dann wird's halt eng so und das ist etwas was sie auch einfach in zukunft grundsätzlich ändern muss.
So zumindest der frage des datenvolumen es hat sich deutschland genährt die deutschen
provider naja also ich sag mal es sind erste schritte telefonica sagt wir bleiben beim datenvolumen aber wir drosseln am ende weniger stark wir drosseln,
auf dreihundert vierundachtzig kilo bit statt
zweiunddreißig kilo bitte ich glaube das ist jetzt makulatur da werden die im zweifelsfall noch noch mehr dann irgendwie machen müssen die deutsche telekom hat gesagt wir geben pauschal zehn
gigabyte obendrauf.
Die müssen aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe einmal mit der mit der app oder über diese pass punkt telekom de dann geklickt werden ja da gibt's dann einmal so ein.
Zehn gigabyte gut.
Die verfallen dann am monatsende also wird es im zweifelsfall auch nächsten monat sein also man sieht die haben sich bewegt bei congstar und den den den prepaid und prost
tarifen da irgendwie werfen sie fünf gigabyte in den ring und ich denke also was man da jetzt sehen wird es nicht alle werden das.
Benötigen weil sie vielleicht schon höre tarife haben und oder durchschnittlich hohes datenvolumen haben oder zu hause in internetanschluss und man sieht dass sie sich jetzt bewegen ja und.
Ja aber sehr langsam also ich bitte dich dreihundert vierundachtzig kilo bitte ist ein witz telefonica hat weil man den höheren tarifen ohnehin schon die drossel nur bei einem megabit dann zehn gigabit und zigarren und.
Dann muss man die auch noch beantragen ich.
Dreihundert vierundachtzig kilo bitten musst du in dem netz erstmal erreichen lieber tim.
Das erreicht man da.
Das halte ich für ein gerücht.
Das ist schon so ich war jetzt mal einen halben monat auf diesem alten megabit grenze und das habe ich schon deutlich gespürt so als das dann wieder weg war das geht schon.
Vodafone hat bisher noch keine änderungen angekündigt wird bestimmt noch kommen da muss natürlich den den druck jetzt aufrecht erhalten und wir werden leider davon sprechen wir die ganze zeit wir sehen jetzt hier die eben dass diese infrastruktur leider insgesamt.
Nicht das verspricht was wir immer auch den bunten plakaten sehen.
Da ganz kurz noch wir sehen bei diesen ersten reaktionen schon die haben ein schlechtes gewissen es gibt diese debatten innerhalb von
mobilfunk an jetzt gerade massiv und es ist deswegen auch nochmal wichtig hinzuweisen die variablen kosten für daten verbrauch wenn das netz schon steht die sind minimal das ist strom und interconnect das ist,
fast nichts was dafür wirklich an kosten bei dem mobilfunk kann anfällt insofern ist es wichtig diese frage zu stellen weil für die menschen an der anderen ende der leitung
ist das sehr wichtig.
So komm wir bleiben bei den mobilfunknetzen.
Und ein großes thema in der letzten zeit ist die verwendung von bewegungsprofilen wir haben das in china gesehen wo es irgendwie ein mehr oder weniger so eine wechat plug-in gab was menschen in irgendwie rot
grün und gelb eingeteilt hat wer rot war durfte nicht wenn's in die in die öffis wer grün es darf sich frei bewegen
und das war also irgendwie.
Schon ein bisschen komisch weil wie auch immer diese app ihre ein ihre einschätzung getroffen hat nicht nicht öffentlich einsehbar war oder so das war die haben ja ohnehin auch sehr.
Interessante sachen diese diese verwendung dieser app wurde im prinzip halt.
Verpflichtend gemacht ne wenn ihr irgendwo reingegangen bist musstest du die zeigen und dass jetzt die öffentlichen verkehrsmittel nicht mehr verwenden konntest dafür hat die app dann schon gesorgt also da sind wir dann in einem sehr.
Krassen eingriff ja jetzt muss man natürlich sagen china hat zumindest was die öffentliche.
Öffentlich verfügbaren zahlen und berichte angeht irgendwie sich inzwischen ja sogar schon ein lob von der who geholt weil sie scheinbar diesen ausbruch.
In ihrem land in griff bekommen haben kaum neu ansteckungen und so aber natürlich maßnahmen die in der schwere jetzt in.
Hoffentlich bei uns nicht denkbar sind südkorea hat irgendwie metadaten internetnutzung gesichtserkennung alles zusammengeworfen um leute in den griff zu bekommen.
Und in deutschland ist jetzt das große thema das die telekom.
Anonymisierte in anführungszeichen anonymisierte bewegung ist daten an das robert koch institut gegeben hat und da haben wir natürlich beim pc auch eine reihe an anfragen zu bekommen.
Was wir denn davon halten ob das jetzt nicht irgendwie der wahnsinn ist oder so was vielen leuten nicht ganz klar ist das ist ein uraltes geschäftsmodell dass sie diese
bewegungs daten haben also wann bewegen sich menschen von von wonach wo und wo entlang und.
Das ist glaube in deutschland hat mir das diskutiert weil das an tom tom gegangen ist ne diese navigations hersteller weil.
Auto irgendwie solche sachen untergebracht hat und was jetzt hier.
In deutschland passiert ist das robert-koch-institut will eben sehen ob die maßnahmen die die bundesregierung ergriffen hat um die bewegung der menschen.
Einzuschränken ob die funktionieren ja gibt es jetzt weniger bewegung bewegung ströme der menschen innerhalb deutschlands oder müssen die maßnahmen.
Stärker sein und ich denke so lange dass diese daten sind die letztendlich von den mobilfunkanbietern seit vielen jahren.
In dieser pseudonymisierung form gehandelt werden und gehandelt werden dürfen.
Denke ich dass wir hier in einem bereich sind dennoch dennoch kein kopfschmerzen machen sollte.
Ich würde sogar sagen ne das ist eine sehr sinnvolle und kreative nutzung dieser daten
ja und in dem moment wo sie halt sonnenvisier anonymisiert wie auch immer da dies skala letztlich aussieht aber eben nicht eindeutig identifizierbar sind
geht das auch vollkommen in ordnung und da muss man eben sowas auch nutzen da ist es halt für mich eher
eine öffentliche information man man könnte quasi mehr oder weniger in echtzeit so eine heatmap der der der aktivität machen und damit eben auch sofort sehen okay wo kann man denn jetzt
gegebenenfalls auch nochmal mit anderen maßnahmen reagieren man während wir hier sprechen hat auch bayern ausgangssperren
angekündigt das kommt jetzt halt nahe uns natürlich sinnvoll möglichst wenig einschränkungen zu haben solange die leute sich selber dran halten aber das tun sie halt teilweise.
Muss man noch eine sache dazu ergänzen also diese daten natürlich sind die
erlauben die eine eine demaskieren von personen ja wenn die beim mobilfunk provider so gesammelt sind das ist halt der sie ja ohnehin der weiß ja ohnehin wer du bist und wo du dich auf auf aufhältst.
Das format wie sie die weitergeben soll schon halbwegs okay sein ja also soll schon stark eingeschränkt sein natürlich könntest du mit diesen daten sehr viel schindluder betreiben ich würde als fazit nur sagen dass robert koch-institut,
ist im zweifelsfalle,
der am wenigsten problematische kunde dieser daten seid ist dieses angebot gibt ja vielleicht können wir uns da als konsens darauf einigen,
ja und die kriegen es jetzt wenigstens kostenlos ja das das ist dieses geschäftsmodell gibt und dass diese daten natürlich nicht einhundertprozentig anonymisiert sind.
Sondern eben rückschlüsse erlauben für bestimmte zeitraum eine bestimmte person wenn man weiß wann die sich wo aufgehalten haben das ist alles kein problem was es hier gibt aber dass das robert koch institut diese daten jetzt hat scheint noch unser.
Geringstes problem aktuell zu sein wie sieht's in österreich aus.
Ja also in in österreich hatten wir
zwei sachen das was du zuletzt gesagt hast ja da wir hatten auch so ein fall von location daten der,
von der eins wo auch proaktiv daten weitergegeben wurden und wie du gesagt hast die frage ist immer sind die sauber aggregiert,
wenn das der fall ist ist es okay da gibt es auch ein statement vom dem european protection board also der höchsten datenschutz einrichtung in europa.
Die das auch so sieht.
Wenn es dann aber um individuelle daten geht wird es natürlich kritisch vor allem weil wenn man dann mit mobilfunknetz location daten arbeitet ist es extrem schwierig zu,
die die strahlt breite einzustellen weil da an der stelle natürlich hunderte menschen auch in das raster reinfallen gerade im urbanen gebiet habe ich immer viele menschen rund um mich das heißt die gefahr dass ich dann
individuelle menschen auch als verdächtig eine stufe wie das im kino passiert ist oder als potenziell infiziert die ist ja groß also ich finde auch bei aggregieren anonymisierten
verfahren da ist die zeit jetzt gekommen bei individuellem tracking hätte ich das datenschützer immer noch zu große bedenken und,
genau solche bedenken waren es auch die uns dazu gebracht haben
die gesetze in österreich zu analysieren die am wochenende beschlossen wurden österreich ist wie gesagt ein zwei wochen vor deutschland weil wir auch näher an italien dran sind und dadurch sehen wir jetzt schon eine reihe von einschränkungen.
Einerseits eben ausgangs beschränkungen es gibt verordnungen die klare regeln war man dass man eigentlich als die folge nicht mehr
das haus verlassen sollte und nur ganz spezifische gründe aus aufgrund derer man sich hinaus bewegen kann wenn man erwischt wird von der polizei muss man die dann
zitat glaubhaft machen dass man auf grund zum beispiel arbeitsweg oder wirklich nur alleine unterwegs sein um um spazieren zu gehen sich gerade draußen aufhält es ist noch
erlaubt irgendwie hilfsleistungen für andere zu erledigen es gibt
doch gerade ganz viel nachbarschaftshilfe um vor allem menschen in risikogruppen das einkaufen abzunehmen der großteil der
der wirtschaft ist runtergefahren also jede art von geschäft ist geschlossen also es ist nicht der komplette,
down von dem linus vorhin gesprochen hat sondern es ist eine recht interessante liste an geschäften die immer noch offen haben kann das sind sachen die man zuerst denken würde wie supermärkte apotheke,
aber dann eben auch greifzug betriebe agrarprodukte also dinge die einfach auch notwendig sind damit die gesellschaft als ganzes auch noch funktionieren kann
und ich habe da auch von regierungsseite mitbekommen wie diese liste erstellt wurde und das war,
da gibt's keine keine playbacks dafür viel davon ist wirklich jetzt on the god geschrieben worden und.
Wir wir wir sind da auch gefragt worden was wir noch eben wie wir das ding sehen und an sich aber.
Wir mussten trotzdem bei einigen punkten kritisieren weil diese gesetze nicht ganz so gut sind wie wir sie uns gewünscht hätten aber insgesamt das war für mich in meiner jetzt schon fast zehn jährigen netzpolitischen karriere das erste mal dass ich das.
Musste aber wir haben diese grundrechte schränke die in diesen gesetzen und verordnungen erlassen wurden zwar sehr kritisch hinterfragt aber am ende.
Sie als verhältnismäßig bewertet weil auch die notwendigen safe guards drinnen sind weil diese gesetze,
ein starkes ablaufdatum haben weiß transparenz bestimmungen gibt da drinnen und weil.
Wirklich der zweck so bestimmt ist das was da jetzt gerade gemacht wird auf der anderen seite stehen halt irgendwie die zu erwartenden
krankheits und todesfälle und der komplette kollaps des des gesundheitssystems und insofern.
Halte ich das noch für verhältnismäßig man muss aber eben wie ich auch ganz am anfang gesagt habe dazu sagen dass auch ganz stark von dem vertrauen in die regierung abhält
die gesetze sind so geschrieben dass das alles temporär alles zweck,
ist und nur dann kann es verhältnismäßig sein in keiner anderen situation könnte ich mir vorstellen dass wir bei sowas nicht
mit einem massendemos auf die straße gehen.
Wie kannst du mal kurz erläutern wie die kommunikation da mit euch gelaufen ist weil du sagtest man hat sich an euch gewendet und inwiefern ist das anders als es vielleicht unter der vorgängerregierung noch stattgefunden hat.
Naja sich wir wir
haben halt jetzt auch dadurch dass es schon schon so lange gibt als organisation ein anderes level an zugang und eigentlich in allen parteien,
gibt es inzwischen leid die sich proaktiv an uns wenden
wir sehen uns da wirklich so als dienstleister wie ein arzt wenn du zu uns gehst kriegst du die neutrale datenschutz grundrecht infos die du gerade brauchst und das auch unter verschiedenheit in vielen fällen
in manchen fällen würden wir es nicht machen bei dem gesetz jetzt konkret was nicht so dass wir vorher eingebettet waren also mir war irgendwie der inhalt der verordnungen
kann aber die sind am sonntag um zweiundzwanzig uhr online gegangen und wandern aber auch schon ab mitternacht in kraft
und an sich wir sind dann am montag gleich mit unserer analyse rausgegangen sobald wir irgendwie das das sechs augen prinzip durch hatten
und ich bin viel am telefon mitleid und gerade aber auch weil alle recht überfordert sind alles in dem homeoffice alle versuchen irgendwie so gut es geht.
Situation umzugehen und da wo es netzpolitische
ist sind wir halt der ansprechpartner in vielen bereichen können wir keine auskunft geben aber da wo wir als als als netzpolitik ngo kompetenz haben wollen wir auch mit.
Empfehlungen und mit ratschlägen unseren teil beitragen und die letzte woche war diese woche jetzt aktuell war wahrscheinlich mit abstand die arbeitsreiche in meinem leben.
Aber gleichzeitig fühle ich mich gut weil wir was beitragen können und weil wir was sinnvolles machen können
und ich kann nur sagen es gibt jetzt zum glück also wenn jetzt jemand wirklich diese krise ausnutzen würde für persönliche bereicherung für platzieren von eigenen produkten oder eben um grundrechte dauerhaft ab zu mildern oder einzuschränken,
der special place in hell jetzt ist der zeitpunkt wo wir alle zusammenhalten müssen.
Ich glaube aber auch dass wenn wir das wenn wir das durchhalten auch psychologisch durchhalten dann kommen wir da durch.
Das ist keine frage ob das ist nur eine frage wann und wie wie spannend der weg dahin wird aber wir verstehen das.
Kurze nachfrage weil's diskussion auch in deutschland ein wenig aufflammt wie das bei euch dann konkret gelöst wurde es gibt ja teilweise hängt dann immer jetzt sehr vom rechtssystem ab aber es gibt ja die möglichkeit für die regierung
qua verordnung solche dinge durchzusetzen und damit vielleicht gegebenenfalls gesetze auch auszusetzen.
Oder eben mit dem parlament das abzustimmen zu beschließen und eben kurzfristige änderungen direkt.
Im gesetzestext auf dem ordentlichen weg ablaufen zu lassen wie ist es jetzt in österreich gelaufen und wie stehst du dazu.
Teils teils also es gibt das epidemie gesetz in österreich was schon eine rechtsgrundlage für solche fälle bietet das ist aber von neunzehnhundertachtzehn und insofern schon ein bisschen.
Aber die ersten maßnahmen zum beispiel verordnungen mit denen gastronomie und restaurants mit einer verordneten sperrstunde von fünfzehn uhr versehen wurden,
kamen auf schnellen dienstweg als verordnung vom grünen gesundheitsminister die erste runde der verschärfungen war über das letzte wochenende,
da waren die gesetze am samstag irgendwie öffentlich erste sitzung nationalrat sonntag durch beide kammern passiert und sonntag gleich unterschrieben vom bundespräsidenten das ist seitdem in kraft
und auf basis dieses gesetzes wurden dann auch schon verordnungen erlassen auch übers wochenende die auch jetzt schon diese woche gelten
jetzt gerade ist freitag wo wir aufnehmen jetzt ist gerade wieder nationalrat und es werden grade die zweite runde an gesetzen beschlossen die gerade auch diesen location und telekommunikations bereich betreffen
die habe ich mir nicht angeschaut weil ich es einfach nicht geschafft habe ich arbeite seit samstag durch aber meine kollegin hat mit zwei anderen,
juristen also wir haben drei leute die da schon analysiert haben max schrems hat auch noch drüber geschaut und das heißt unsere analyse davon ist auch schon seit gestern abend fertig und schon an die medien ergangen,
und da konnten wir da haben wir detail kritikpunkte gehabt aber im großen und ganzen weiß auch nicht so der große überwachung statt drinnen.
Aber wie gesagt ich hab's mir persönlich diese gesetze nicht angeschaut wir sind ja doch elf leute bei center wachs insofern sind doch irgendwie,
zum glück mehrere schultern auf die das gerade fällt das ist auch der letzte punkt den ich noch bringen will bevor ich zu diesem interview muss.
Wir fragen uns natürlich auch wie wird es mit unseren spenden weitergehen wir waren davor schon eine prekäre organisation an wissen auch nicht so ob.
Jetzt menschen wenn sie ihren job verlieren das erste wo man spart sind die spenden die man ausgibt und das ist uns vollkommen bewusst.
Gleichzeitig,
wir wollen weitermachen mit dem team das wir haben weil ich glaube wir sind jetzt besonders gefordert in dieser zeit und hat einfach wirklich schauen dass wir.
Den betrieb aufrecht erhalten können weil ich glaube dass auch zivilgesellschaft hier als als public watchdog besonders in der pflicht ist gerade in der krise geht's ganz massiv um grundrechte um
dem neutrale beobachtung auch journalistinnen und journalisten sind heute in einer ganz wichtigen rolle.
Und wir versuchen das so gut es geht eben für europa und österreich zu sein.
Ja ihr seid nämlich im epizentrum jetzt des geschehens an der stelle.
Der.
Passt der name mal wieder richtig gut link auf eure spendenseite ist natürlich auch in den shownotes.
Ja und ich denke dann kommen wir auch langsam ans ende linus hast du noch was hinzuzufügen.
Ja ich würde so mir fällt grundsätzlich eben auf dass das jetzt so ein bisschen am.
Wir blicken wahrscheinlich darauf dass wir etwas länger jetzt zuhause sitzen da dem haben wir uns in der letzten sendung schon gewidmet ich beobachte jetzt so langsam um mich herum
das was das eben auch für diese welt da draußen bedeutet die ich unter normalen bedingungen besuche und.
Ich hatte ja eingangs schon dieses united stream erwähnt und ähm dann habe ich hier noch von einer,
berliner kneipe mit dem namen beilage die vielleicht einigen berlinerinnen und berlinern etwas sagt ein schönen hinweis in den.
In den shownotes verlinkt die mal so ein bisschen zeigen ok was ist jetzt unsere finanzielle situation hier mit miete versicherung und laufenden kosten.
Die können nicht mehr öffnen und,
da ist natürlich klar dass das den die beschreiben da mal so welche maßnahmen sie ergriffen haben wie viel geld sie jetzt im prinzip bräuchten
ja wenn sie den laden irgendwie retten wollen in die zeit die nach dem unweigerlich ende all dieser maßnahme irgendwann einmal sehe sein wird und dann eben sagen na wenn uns.
So und so viele menschen mit einem zehner so und so viele menschen mit dreißig euro oder so unterstützen können können wir irgendwie dieses defizit schultern bis in den und können die.
Können in den nächsten winter uns retten ja und das wird für viele.
Eurer lieblingsorte da draußen sein dass eure lieblingsrestaurants sein dass eure.
Lieblingskneipen oder sonstigen öffentlichen orte die ihr besucht wird es jetzt der fall sein und ich würde hoffen dass diejenigen die irgendwie in krisenfesten einstellungen sind hier.
Entdecken dass es unter umständen nötig sein wird jetzt eure lieblingsorte und eure,
lieblingsinstrument utti onen irgendwie tatsächlich mit der absolut widersinnig
idee einer spende durch diese durch diese zeit zu bringen
einfach damit die noch da sind weil wenn ihr wenn dieser mist vorbei ist und ihr kommt da raus und eure lieblings eure lieblingskneipen kollektiv hat's erwischt dann wisst ihr,
auch das da als nächstes irgendso ein prenzelberg der kaffee ist was ihr da auch nicht haben wollt und dann werdet ihr euch irgendwie die nächsten jahre darüber ärgern dass ihr da das mit dem dass das korona euch die schönsten orte kaputt gemacht hat.
Da lohnt sich jetzt langsam mal so ein bisschen drüber nachzudenken bisschen zu schauen und das funktioniert eben,
wie so vieles am besten mit vielen menschen die kleinstbeträge geben weniger als mit wenigen menschen die große beträge geben da werdet ihr in eurem umfeld,
sicherlich ein bisschen in zukunft schauen müssen.
Das gilt natürlich auch für die podcast ich hatte in den letzten tagen auch so ein paar einzelspenden gesehen die so auf mich den eindruck machen dass hier leute von sich aus heraus schon
unterstützung geben wollen das finde ich natürlich super an der stelle kann man auch gleich nochmal sagen besser ihr macht sowas auf.
Zu einer.
Dauerauftrags kleinst spendenbasis als jetzt große beträge rauszuhauen es sei denn ihr habt so dicke dann natürlich auch gerne aber ich glaube wichtig ist für alle eben diese planbarkeit.
Ein grundrauschen an finanzierung mit dem man irgendwie arbeiten kann um sich einfach auf die nächste zeit gut einstellen zu können das gilt sicherlich auch für viele andere gruppen
ich denke wir werden noch einige interessante ansätze für crowdfunding und dauer unterstützung für,
andere gruppen organisationen einzelne personen et cetera sehen in der nächsten zeit müssen abwarten was der staat dazu beitragen kann.
Wird auf jeden fall eine interessante herausforderung und immerhin hat diese gesellschaft mal was was ernstes mit dem sie sich beschäftigen kann und nicht immer.
Tri tra trullala bin ich netz.
Ich glaube das wird dir zu wenig netz wird auf jeden fall noch ein dickeres thema bleiben.
Ich glaube auch anyway thomas vielen dank.
Danke euch.
Und du musst dich jetzt gleich verabschieden für dein nächstes interview aber wir verabschieden uns auch die nuss stimmt's.
Ja ich würde natürlich auch noch ganz kurz den michael gerne danken und sonstiger dank kommt dann in der nächsten sendung die dieses mal gar nicht so lange auf sich warten lassen wird.
Genau weil wir haben eine menge zu berichten wir bleiben auf jeden fall dran für euch bis dahin bleibt gesund und bis bald.
Tschau tschau.